the international atomic energy agency
says there is no critical impact on
safety right now but that losing power
at the defunct chernobyl plant violates
a fundamental safety precaution the
facility was seized by russian troops in
the first hours of the invasion
now ukraine says power lines to the
facility have been cut by fighting in
the area emergency diesel generators
have kicked in but according to the
ukrainian foreign affairs minister they
can only power the plant for 48 hours
in a tweet he says after that cooling
systems of the storage facility for
spent nuclear fuel will stop making
radiation leaks imminent the iaea says
for now there is enough water in the
cooling reservoirs but it also confirms
its access to sensors at the facility
has been cut this canadian nuclear
expert says he trusts the u.n agency but
he'd like it to be there
they should be allowed into the facility
and all the facilities in the ukraine
so that we do have an expert and
independent voice on these issues and it
seems like that communication has been
cut off which which is disturbing in
itself
now there are also developments with the
zapariza nuclear power plant russia
attacked and seized that facility last
friday the biggest nuclear power plant
in europe ukraine's energy minister is
accusing russian troops of holding the
staff hostage russia propaganda machine
he also claims the staff is being forced
to participate in a video that's being
produced to depict everything as being
fine
the russian foreign ministry meantime
says its troops seized the facilities to
prevent ukrainian nationalists and
terrorists from causing a nuclear
problem
now of the two the zapariza plant is
more modern and less likely to be a
problem in terms of radiation leaks
chernobyl is older but it does have two
containment structures over it the last
one was put in place just six years ago
experts say if there was a problem it
shouldn't be as serious as it would have
been without those containment
structures it wouldn't spread as widely
but it could be a real problem for staff
donna
mike armstrong in
ukraine thanks